翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Kyoko Kamura
みなさんのお時間を
５分ほどいただきたいと思います
その間で 私のアイデアをこの場で
発表させていただけたらなと思います
私のアイデアは
ことばの力というものです
ことばの力 どういうことかと言いますと
みなさん 薄々気づいてるとは思うんですが
この世界にはことばが
あふれていますよね？
至る所にことばがあります
本を開けば書き言葉がありますし
その書いてあることばを読めば
そこで自分の頭で中で読んだことばが
くるくるくるくる回転すると思うんです
そのようにこの世界には
ことばがあふれていて
色んな所にことばがあるのに
僕たちは普段
きっとまだことばの力というものを
全部引き出せていないんじゃないか
っていうふうに考えていました
具体的にどういうことかって言いますと
ことばっていうのは
色んな要素でできていますよね？
でも普段私たちは そのことばの中にある
意味ばかり[を]多分気にしてると思うんです
意味ばかりを気にして生活しているんです
けれど 意味以外のところ—
例えば 形であったり 音であったりを
意識してみたときに また面白い発見があるん
じゃないかっていう風に僕は考えていまして
今日はその発見の成果を
少し紹介したいなと思います
まず1つ目なんですが これは形がすごい
面白いなと思ったことばで
２文字からなることばです
平仮名で 「しり」
（笑）
いいですか みなさん—
紙をお持ちの方—
紙とペンをお持ちの方
どうぞ出していただいて
書いて下さい 実際に
「しり」ですよ？尻です
いいですか？「しり」です
「し」「り」ってこう—
ゆっくり 大きく「しり」って
ちょっと近づけて書くと
本当にお尻の形に見えるんです
（笑）
本当ですよ みなさん
実際に書いて確かめて下さい
しり—お尻の形に見えます
形が面白いことば その１—
「しり」でした
次はちょっと時間がないんで
音の面白いことば
行きたいと思います
音の面白いことば—
そうですね
「しり」ときましたから
つぎは「おっぱい」でいきましょうか？
（笑）
どうでしょう？「おっぱい」
そうですね—
３つに区切ってみる
っていうのはどうですかね？
「おっ」と「ぱ」と「い」
３つに区切りましょう
まず１つ目いきますよ—
「お」です
みなさん 言ってみましょう
せーの
（会場全体）おっ
「おっ」は「お」と小さい「っ」ですよね？
「お」って大きく口を開けるんですけど
そのあと小さい「っ」できゅっと止まりますよね
つまり口から出たことばのエネルギーが
一点にぎゅっと
凝縮するようなイメージを持ってください
いいですか？
次 「ぱ」ですよ いきますよ
せーの
（会場）「ぱ」
はい ありがとうございます
「ぱ」は皆さんご存知のように
破裂音なんですね
破裂音ですから
「お」で貯めたエネルギーが
「ぱ」で一気に爆発するような
そんなイメージですね
さあ 次に行きましょう 最後です
「い」ですよ 行きますよ
皆さん「い」って言いましょう
「いー」ってそのまま隣の人の顔を
ちょっと見ていただいて
「いー」
ね 自然と どうですか？ 口角が上がって
皆んな笑顔になってませんか？
ね 素晴らしい
「お」で貯めて 「ぱ」で解放して
「い」で笑顔になる
こんな素晴らしい４文字のことばです
魔法のことばですよ 皆さん
「おっぱい」は魔法のことばなんです
（拍手）
「しり」で「おっぱい」—
ちょっとキャッチーなことばで
今回は行かせていただいたんですけども
大変 分かっていただけたら
嬉しいなと思います
本当にこのようにことばっていうのは
僕たちが普段意識している意味以外にも
音や形 —
もしかしたら 僕がまだ気づいていない
それ以外の要素によって隠された力が
きっと眠っているっていう風に
思っているんです
そして何よりも 冒頭でも言いましたけど
ことばっていうのは
この世界にあふれていますよね
色んな所にことばがあります
電車に乗ってたら 中吊り広告とか
皆さんがぶら下げてる名札
自分の名前 裏のキャッチコピー
至る所にことばがあります
そのことばを今一度 意識して見てみて
こういう風に見たら
面白いんじゃないか
新しい発見があるんじゃないか
そういう風にしてことばの力をどんどん
見つけていっていただきたいと思っています
皆さんいいですか？
ことばは — 世界はことばにあふれています
世界はことばにあふれている
世界 — 英語で行きましょうか？
世界 — 英語で言うと？
（会場）ワールド
（話者）ことば — 英語で言うと？
（会場）ワード
ワールド — ワード
わ 似てる！
（笑）（拍手）
そうです 皆さんいいですか？
世界はことばであふれています
今一度皆さんが普段何気なく接していることばに
目を向けて新しい発見をして
少しでも人生を 豊かに 充実[させ]てくれるような
お手伝いが
今日のこのお話でできれば
嬉しいなと思っています
以上で終わりたいと思います
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）